[Music]
right breakfast in the great smoky
mountains um i've had the most amazing
week with one of the best chefs on the
planet uh william dessen he has the
marketplace restaurant in asheville and
it has been a journey and a half but
what i did find this week
was some of the best ingredients
anywhere from the best pigs to the best
mushrooms crawfish trout you name it so
i'm gonna do a breakfast based on that
experience that i've had this week a
great smoky mountain breakfast with a
twist um beautiful chanterelle look at
the color of these these aren't just any
ingredients these are mushrooms that are
literally foraged from 10 meters away
from here now start off with the
shallots a little bit of garlic
normally put the garlic in whole take it
out but
with those mushrooms the flavor is
incredible so
caramelise the garlic
caramelise the shallots
and then get the
water out of those mushrooms and get
flavour on there
set up
your table i've got what they call a
biscuit but that's gonna be my base for
my eggs i'm gonna do there turn that
over and literally just
put a little bit of mustard on there
okay
and let that seep in
season that with a touch of chili fake
in there
now
bacon
now this is beautiful local bacon
over to the stove
touch
just a touch of oil
so bacon goes in
look at that
so beautiful
now once that bacon fat starts to run
out i'm gonna put my biscuits in
okay but i want some flavor first
this one's gonna be done ready for the
mushrooms garlic in mushrooms in
butter
so here we go mushrooms shallots
garlic and butter
so
get that cooking beautifully
look at that
the smell of those mushrooms is
incredible and that bacon look at that
get that
in that is so beautiful
now whilst we've got that bacon fat
there
tilt the pan down until the fat runs
away
and gets
your biscuits in
you can see what i'm going to do now i'm
going to mop up that amazing flavor with
the mustard
get that in
and that's going to put a lovely flavor
on that incredible biscuit
mushroom's getting lots of color
now
look at those mushrooms
so beautiful the colors as they cook
it almost sort of bursts like a bright
orange
from the sunshine
get that bacon fat running down into the
biscuit
get it really nice and crispy
now for my eggs
with the eggs i like to cook the eggs
with a little bit of heat
touch of olive oil in first
then get your butter in get that froth
get that frothing
it's so hot here
a little touch
of chili seeds in there okay
turn my biscuit over oh my lord
look at that
you can't buy that flavor
look at that bacon
so beautiful
eggs
start cracking
now get the eggs in
flat surface
in
and crack
and crack nicely
beautiful
take my biscuit out
i get set
on my plate
ready to roll
beautiful
so beautiful
now a little trick
with this bacon
a little
delays
with this this is apple moonshine and
trust me
he's got a kick stronger than mule
that's going to glaze the bacon in she
goes
oh
man
look at that
50 percent alcohol
look at that season the top of the eggs
butter
is doing its magic
popping over chili's giving a little bit
of heat to the eggs
beautiful
look at that blister
and look at that bacon now reduce that
bacon all the way down to absolutely
evaporates
and then we start
the magical moment we start to assemble
this
first off
get your eggs
and just open them up
nicely lift that out with the chili
and just sit that
on one
side of your biscuit look at those
mushrooms
i mean
the color
is ridiculous the smell
is amazing get that bacon it's gotten
slightly crispy but sort of caramelized
give it a little bit of height so it
gives a bit of beauty on the plate
and then finally
i've got some beautiful smoky mountain
beans
and that's going to just sit right at
the very top
and when i said to you
it is a smoky mountains breakfast
trust me
that is a breakfast of champions
because right now with that in my hands
i feel as happy
as a bear up a tree with his hands in a
honey pot
or as local would say
happy as a pig in shed
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus
[Music]